-So now I thought
I'd share some of
my favorite summer songs
from you guys,
and here to help me out and sing
them is tonight's musical guest,
Camila Cabello!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Camila!
-Hello, Jimmy.
-Thank you for coming back.
-Thank you for having me.
-I love the new song and --
-I love you.
-We love you.
Yeah, you're the greatest.
I love you so much.
You ready to do this, Camila?
-I'm ready.
-All right, here we go. This
first one's from @skysosmart.
And she says...
♪♪
-♪ Am I too late
to the pool party? ♪
♪ 'Cause I can bring
another pool floatie ♪
♪ Oh, whoa ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I can bring
another pool floatie.
-Yeah, why not?
-I can bring
another pool floatie.
-Come on, man.
-This one is
from @Mattmorgan182.
He says...
♪♪
-♪ It's getting hot out here ♪
♪ So let's just go inside ♪
♪ I am getting so hot ♪
♪ I'm gonna turn this hose on ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm gonna turn this hose on.
This one's from @Tedsabby.
And he says...
♪♪
-♪ Don't go chasing
ice cream trucks ♪
♪ Just stick to the popsicles ♪
♪ And shakes
that you're used to ♪
♪ Oh, yeah, yeah ♪
-Don't go chasing
ice cream trucks.
-That you're used to.
-Yeah, stick to the ones
that you're used to.
-This next one is actually based
on one of your songs, Camila.
-One of my songs?
-Yeah, absolutely.
This one is from --
This one's from @skippycabello.
-Skippy Cabello.
-I like the username a lot.
-All right, ready?
And she says...
-It would be bad
if I wasn't ready, huh?
♪♪
♪ Number one,
tell me why did you get burned ♪
♪ When I know that you've got
sunscreen in your purse ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Why would you get burned?
I know you got sunscreen
in your purse.
Answer me. I have a question.
-Hey.
-This one's from
@overtiredkatie.
Aw, poor Kate.
She's overtired.
-But still has time to tweet.
[ Laughter ]
-She's come around.
And she said --
Oh, this is great.
♪♪
-♪ Hello from the water slide ♪
I must've rode
a thousand times ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on!
-Thanks.
-I would buy "Hello from
the Water Slide" right now.
-I would, too.
That was my favorite one.
-My next single on iTunes.
-This one's from @itsalexadiane.
-Oh, I love this one.
-Oh, yeah.
Oh, maybe it's --
it's Alexa, Diane.
[ Laughter ]
-I corrected it.
-It's like -- it's like,
"Uh, it's Alexa, not Alexy."
-She wants us to get it right.
-Yeah.
-I respect her for that. I do.
-It's just one person
she wants to get it.
She wants Diane to get it right.
-Mm-hmm.
It's "Alexa," Diane.
-It's "Alexa," Diane.
[ Laughter ]
-And she's like,
"It's Diana, Alexa." Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Yes, it is, Jimmy.
-And she says...
♪♪
-♪ All I do is swim,
swim, swim no matter what ♪
♪ Got sunshine on my mind ♪
♪ I can never get enough ♪
-Oh, my God. Come on!
-That's the one I get crunk to.
I was so excited for that one.
I'm not gonna lie.
-You went and got crunk --
You got crunk to that one?
-Yep.
-I was gonna say that.
[ Laughter ]
She got crunk to that one.
-Got crunked?
-This one is from @fakedanesh.
♪♪
-♪ I believe I will fry ♪
♪ From the heat
coming from the sky ♪
♪ I have the A/C on
all night and day ♪
♪ Now there's more bills
that I got to pay ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I want this --
I want this album.
-It's the summer --
It's the summer tweets mix tape.
You and I should drop it.
-Let's drop it.
I mean, let's make this record.
Let's do it.
-Let's make this record, Jimmy.
-I will get crunked
and I will --
I will get crunked,
and I will drop it.
-You're going to drop it
and get crunked.
-Yeah, that's the only way
I do it.
I don't get crunk
and hold on to it.
-No.
-You drop it. As soon as you get
crunked, guess what.
Album dropping.
-It's up to you what happens.
-[ Laughing ]
This sounds so dirty.
I get crunked,
and then I drop it.
-You can drop it,
and it's up to you what happens.
-As long as you don't get turnt.
-I don't even want
my fingerprints on it.
-Nope, flush it.
-'Cause you dropped it.
-Yeah, I dropped it, man.
I crunked out.
-You dropped it like its hot.
That's great.
-This one is from @septacular23.
Oh, I like this jam.
♪♪
-♪ Oh, I wanna
grill with somebody ♪
♪ I wanna grill ♪
♪ I want to cook hot dogs
with somebody ♪
♪ Yeah, I wanna
grill with somebody ♪
♪ With somebody who loves food ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh!
I'll miss that.
That's a great song.
-Wow.
-♪ With somebody ♪
I love that jam.
This last one is also based on
one of your songs.
-You guys are so nice to me
here. thanks.
-Yeah, they love you.
-That was actually
the first time
that I came on your show,
this song.
-This one?
-Yeah, this one.
-Oh, that's right.
Do you remember that?
-Yeah, that's when I was
crapping myself.
-What?
-Like, I was --
I was really nervous.
I was like,
"I don't know what to do."
-You were fantastic.
-Oh, thank you.
I feel like we're friends now,
even if you don't know.
[ Laughter ]
So I'm less nervous now.
-I totally know.
Are you kidding me?
-Oh, really? We're best friends?
-Yeah.
-In fact, I sent this one in
to the hashtag game, yeah.
-Yay.
[ Laughter ]
-'Cause I love you so much.
-That's your secret twitter.
-No, no, this ones from...
-You got to let it drop.
-...@intoyoucabello.
-Oh, yay, hi.
-Yeah, @intoyoucabello,
and here we go.
She says...
♪♪
♪ I know what
you did last summer ♪
♪ Dropped my ice cream,
what a bummer ♪
♪ I know what
you did last summer ♪
♪ It melted on my shoe ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on!
Can you beat that?
Camila Cabello!
-Yay!
-Those were our hashtags.
Camila, thank you so much.
-Thank you so much, Jimmy!
-To check out more of
our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.